uh and number two he has to make it he
has to make it very clear to her early
on that she is going to help him with
his program I remember dude I think it
was what three or four months in uh to
Dev and I talking she Built My she built
the the first version of my website all
right yeah
she built the she built the website a
month before that she bought and paid
for the entire for our entire Hawaii
vacation wow eight thousand dollar trip
she footed the she footed the and the
the the entire bill at that point quick
question Devin were you were you nervous
at all because you weren't dating right
we're more talking yeah so yeah we
weren't I mean we weren't dating we were
right yeah we're I mean we were listen
we were sleeping together and that was
pretty much it yeah so at that point
there was no commitment what do you say
to girls that say you can't do too much
for a man before you have the commitment
I'll actually answer that
um a lot of women
want and this is this is such a huge
women make so many mistakes when it
comes to relationships but one of the
biggest mistakes that women make is not
understanding that they have to audition
for the part women tell well I'm not
going to give him girlfriend benefits
until he makes me my girlfriend well a
guy like me who has options I'm not
going to give you the title of
girlfriend until you can prove that you
can be a girlfriend I'm not going to
give him long-term relationship benefits
without him giving me the long-term
relationship commitment there are more
of you than there are of me so it is on
you to qualify to me so so at the end of
the day women want a women want to be
awarded a part that they have neither
auditioned for nor can prove that they
can play it uh a famous play I don't
know uh The Sound of Music right uh I
don't know what the the the the the main
characters female leap they did not give
that lead to uh they didn't give that
lead I think it might have been Julie
Andrews in the movie they didn't give
that lead to a woman oh you know what I
think I should play the main character
okay well you have to watch it no no no
no you need to give me the part no that
is literally women expecting long-term
relationship benefits before they're
actually committed to that's like a
that's like someone demanding a part in
a play that they have not auditioned for
look if you want the title you need to
audition for the title if I can't see a
willingness for you to audition and then
the ability to be with a guy like me
then guess what it's going to remain
strictly casual that's just all there is
to it and it's it's funny women get into
situation chips or entanglements with
with guys all the time then they meet
one they really like six seven eight
months down the line they think well why
hasn't Eric committed to me because you
have you think that you're entitled to
his commitment you haven't shown him any
sign you haven't shown him any sign that
you want to be in a relationship other
than flapping at the gums hey I want a
relationship actions speak louder than
words don't tell them you want to be in
a relationship show him because he needs
to see that you are equal to the task
because if all you're doing is yapping
at the gums we always say well I guess
she's all talking no show that's why he
keeps banging you and not committing
yeah
or chicken and egg argument there's a
common Trope that guy says like why buy
the cat why buy the milk if the cow is
free no why buy the cow
it's why buy the cow we can get the milk
for free
no no why buy the cow why do we have to
buy the cow see you give the cow to get
the milk right why buy the cow if you
can get the milk for free basically but
basically why commit to a woman when you
can just get the sex without the
commitment that's what it is that's what
really what guys say go ahead continue
well the way I have it figured it made
sense now it doesn't so never mind
I was gonna say man taking care of a cow
is on chore well no no but your point is
well founded because taking care of a
woman is a chore but why but but here's
the thing women or women or cows the
most valuable ass the most valuable
thing a cow has to offer is milk right
and so if a man has to buy the cow in
order to get the milk the then he is
going to buy the cow back in the day if
you wanted to have sex with a woman you
needed to be married to her well guess
what they had been a feminism a hormonal
birth control Roe v Wade was now well no
now
the the point is is that women are
giving away the milk without requiring
men to buy the cow they're giving away
their bodies without requiring
commitment and so guys are like wait a
minute you mean I don't have to be in a
committed relationship to have sex girls
are just giving it away without any sort
of commitment great and then these women
on the back end wonder why guys don't
want to commit to them because you're
giving them the commitment benefits
without actually requiring the
commitment that's why we got these
others running around
[Music]
um so
sorry
[Music]
okay so um
the The Next Step so first he has to
make sure she's put in the effort she's
putting in the commitment are there [__]
tests that women commonly do early I've
heard this term and I don't think I
don't know if it's
if women [__] test like on purpose
because some of the stuff that I hear
guys talk about that are [__] tests I
think they're kind of on accident to us
it's not on accident it's the way you
guys are designed [__] tests [__] tests
vary depending on the situation if
you're at a bar or club trying to pick
up a woman women [__] test you on
purpose I don't date Black guys answer
oh neither do I I mean can you imagine
dude I get a laugh at that I Gotta Laugh
at that every time
um when women [__] test you in that
social Pua scenario they just want to
make sure that you have experience with
women women in relationships [__] tests
on [__] test on autopilot This Is Not a
Bad Thing women have to [__] test what
women are doing here is they're biting
the gold and women have to [__] test
their men every so often to make sure
that he is still the man that that she
fell in love with
um so in relationships women [__] test
on autopilot now there's a big
difference between [__] tests and
disrespect if a [__] if a supposed [__]
test makes you feel upset or angry and
that's not a [__] test that's disrespect
but for men to not expect affect a woman
a woman who doesn't test a man is not
interested in a man you can welcome to a
girl and start chatting her up and blah
blah blah blah oh man she has some [__]
test to me then you go in for the number
close and she tells you well I have a
boyfriend or well blah blah blah blah
and you're like what the hell she never
[__] tested you because she never was
interested in you in the first place
women women will [__] test men as a in
relationships women will indirectly [__]
test men as a matter of re-confirmation
rather than disqualification now there
are impassable [__] tests at which point
your woman has already lost respect for
you the the relationship is likely going
to be over but [__] tests are a good
thing if your woman if your woman is not
[__] testing you in a relationship it
means one of two things either number
one you're doing it right and you don't
give her a reason to [__] test you or
number two she just needs to she needs
to pinch herself a little bit and kind
of put a and and just make sure okay is
this the guy that I'm meant to be with
is this guy the same and can I have a
couple examples of a [__] test that you
should break up with a girl over and a
[__] test that this is how you would
handle it
a breakup with a girl over in a long
term or short-term relationship let's
say long term because I think a lot of
my audience is looking for wives more
than short-term relationships if they
want pickups
that would wow that's that's a very good
question
um what is the kind of [__] test if I
were to get a [__] test well here's the
thing a [__] test is just that it's a
test if a [__] test leads to a breakup
in a man's mind then chances are either
you are too weak to pass the [__] test
and just didn't have it in you or what
she did was disrespect so a lot of girls
think that mentioning hey my ex tested
texted me today they think that's a [__]
test that is not a [__] test that is
disrespect if now before the
relationship you make it clearer listen
I don't commit to women who stay in
contact with people who have been inside
of them so the minute she tells you hey
my texted me my my ex my text next to me
my my ex texted me and I responded and
they've been going back and forth well
guess what she just she just broke up
with you because she engaged in the
behavior that makes her a kind of woman
that you don't date so that's the kind
of quote-unquote [__] test that will end
the relationship her putting herself her
wanting to put your relationship your
supposed relationship at risk and
telling you about it that's not a [__]
test that's disrespectful yeah that was
my um
thought as well was if she's like hey
I'm going to I'm going out to lunch with
so and so from work male co-worker
um
uh ignore what your feelings are and I
think that's that's that is important
um when you start operating without the
consideration of the person that you
supposedly love your relationship is
over
and that's what you guys do in a lot of
your skits right you'll go through
different scenarios that maybe some men
used to put up with or that's a
situation that they've been in and and
your your message is you don't have to
accept this you can walk away so you
don't have to put women on a pedestal
right I think what most men and most men
especially in the west they have no idea
just how much more valuable they are as
people than the women they are pursuing
just because dude listen man I have
known some extremely beautiful women who
are extremely low value people yeah
they're cool and they're cool to hang
out with and do drugs with and all and
all this other kind of stuff but they
don't have a pot to piss in they're
crass they act like men a lot of them
dropped out of high school they're just
they're just trash people
um and and it's funny it's it the more
attractive a woman is I'm trying to tell
you I've been through I've been through
enough attractive women to know and
understand this to be 100 true the more
attractive of a woman is the less
valuable she tends to be the more of an
attitude she tends to have the more
entitled she tends to be the more she
tends to nag because attractive women
get the benefit of the doubt and
attractive women live the attractive
women in the United States in the west
they live the best lives of any class of
human on the planet regardless of their
behavior that's just how this is Amber
Heard is really the first attractive
woman who has ever been taken to task
over the [__] behavior that she put
a man through only because she tried the
okie doke on him but if you're expecting
an attractive woman to just fall in line
because you think she's a good person
because she's attractive you're gonna
have another thing coming
there's a comment that said should a
woman have any male friends
she can have listen should a woman have
any male friends in terms of what a
relationship yeah in a relationship
I mean a woman is entitled to see what I
guess what he needs to I guess the
question really is should I accept the
fact that my long-term girlfriend has
male friends the answer is no you should
not accept that the only exceptions are
if her male friend is gay
um her hair no seriously one of her one
of her hairdressers his name was Travis
dude coolest dude coolest guy in the
world if Devin wanted to go and hang out
with him and all that listen go knock
yourself out
um but that's the only exception um male
friends are um male friends now here's
the thing you cannot tell your woman
what she can or cannot do you can't do
that you can't control women nor should
you seek to control them but what you
can do is you can control your behavior
so when guys asked well is having male
friends acceptable well only if you
accept it if you make yourself scarce if
you let your woman know through your
words and actions hey look if you have
male friends that's cool we're just
gonna keep it casual if we're in a
committed relationship and all of a
sudden you start befriending males guess
what it's going to it's going to devote
all from a long-term relationship to uh
to something casual that's all there is
to it you don't have to [__] you don't
have to fight you don't have to argue if
she engages in activities that put your
relationship at risk just don't agree
the relationship no problem at all
and so that's why it's so important to
have that up front your expectations
right
yeah absolutely and do you think a lot
of guys are afraid to say that up front
because of things like feminism and like
the modern of course I don't like dude I
mean like back when back when I actually
read the comments in in the chat and all
that you can see women anytime I mention
anytime I mention that you know you have
to protect a woman from herself oh my
God you're toxic and this and that in
the third guys see this stuff and so
when they get into relationships of
their own or interactions with women on
their own they're like well I don't want
to be toxic I don't want to be insecure
I don't want to be I don't want to be
jealous I don't want to be you know
considered to be one of these possessive
boyfriends so that that really sort of
nips that in the bud never be afraid as
a man to set boundaries if if she does
not allow you to set boundaries dude no
sweat off your back simply downgrade the
relationship to casual or just a
one-time fling and keep it moving that's
all you got to do you can't control
women man you can't do it and what I
like about you too is you also put a lot
of accountability on men you you don't
just hold women accountable you hold
them unaccountable too what are the
common complaints you hear from women
about men and how can men improve in
their relationships
uh good God that's a well I don't really
get too many complaints uh about sorry
about valid complaints as
just
bad talk and are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible